questa rete di ragazzi venuti a questo
nuovo fantasmagorico video di oggi siamo
su una perla dell'horror mondiale visto
che è uscita la demo di resident i v8 in
calo fino al 7 riuscita a demolire
sentivo lotto come è uscita su
playstation 5 ho detto che proviamo la e
facciamola uscire perché secondo me io
sono nato coi giochi oro non potevo non
fare questa cosa quindi è che si parte
subito un'atmosfera tranquilla
sono contento che le partenze del giorno
siano sempre e sguazzare nella melma
però va bene fugge dai sotterranei non
guarda volevo stare quanto ancora perché
mi piace leccare la ruggine dalla porta
beh allegro meno ma comunque una torcia
ocio gli occhi che illuminano una torcia
incorporata nel fantastico madonna che
grafica ragazzo sta roba
mi ricorda l'inizio ovviamente i
residenti con sette dove effettivamente
residenti volo è diventato e amici che è
successo ho sentito rumori bruttissimi
proprio nove ragazzi sono prison break
regga su fenomeno stato subisco la via
non so se effettivamente si debba fare
così ma a questo alimentari ok non c'è
niente ma la data è una pistolina giusto
per difendermi visto che ho sentito
rumori strani salve ragazzi adesso
spunta pitt di penombra nord ditemi che
ve lo ricordate perché allora ghazi
siamo in mezzo alla prigione di stockar
vedremo di riuscire a trovare cos'è sta
roba
non lo so ma di sicuro non sono le
caramelle tutti i gusti più 1 vela
giorno c'è un tizio ragazzi è un
problema il fatto che non abbia le gambe
se come non mi servono in questo momento
provo sempre meglio averle se non si sa
mai comunque tutto chiuso sorpassato hub
è comoda poltrone sofà
giorno ma non l'avevo vista questa prima
come ho fatto a non vederlo a salve ed
elettro eco in pace delle tronchesi
nella schiena perché mi sembra il posto
giusto dove riporre le tronchesi la
prossima volta pro villa tasca comunque
tutto sto casino trovato le tronchesi la
cosa principale perché per adesso è il
casinò era proprio allora chiariamo
subito una cosa no netgear bellissimo
per adesso tutto liscio ma è solo
cascato un cadavere in faccia ma vabbè
quello succede spesso nei giochi horror
a vino vino tinozza di vino si
giustamente c'era un grimaldello nel b
questo non è vino comunque però diciamo
vino perché se non siete monetizzabile
ragazzi sentono i rumori ogni tre
secondi più brutti quindi è veramente
dobbiamo muoverci i palpiti al cuore
aspetto nelle cuffie vabbè allora fate
voi che cazzo vuoi la madonna mi chiudo
qui no no no no no no no mi chiudo mi
chiedo sono chiuso mi chiudo sono qua
signori vado a giocare all happy with
wells hack'n'slash minchia ma chi ci
vuole andare a di via via via via via
fuori alle palle grimaldello vai veloce
e signori io me ne vado ma fuori dalle
palle velocissimo a preti però
controtempo lanciano la lega la pira
rete che brevemente veloce dove va beh
non ragazzi abbiamo incredibile questa
porta dell'inferno
l'entrata delle mie superiori c c'è
qualcuno che cammina l'ho visto è
sentita sa sento camminare io ero nel
casino aspetta che
che puzza 3 mag e sicuramente questo non
è il succo di zucca va bene dell'autore
non me ne frega una serie the macabre di
sicuro non è gigi da google sul cd
comunque diamo avanti è permesso devo
continuare a strisciare per terra
questa cosa mi piace molto bene per
ferite non ho mai coltivato e la madonna
porta e alta alta tecnologia questa
signori siamo in tutto sto casino
scusami invece una scala no no non
spuntare data mazzotta masso 6 punti non
rispettato nessuno sono tutti i cliché
degli horror che non stanno succedendo
meno male perché quindi siamo usciti
dalle miniere cioè dalle prigioni che mi
è la miccia ragazzi è diventato al mese
sul serio no vabbè ma è bellissimo c'è
una casa gigante va bene collana belle e
gr meno male qualcosa che c'è quindi tu
fammi capire dietro l'armadio cioè delle
prigioni meglio saperlo non ti
frequenterò mai però vabbè io non lo
bevo qua dentro te ma soprattutto non
c'era the qua dentro c'è una qualsiasi
altra cosa ma di sicuro non il tè a meno
che non fosse ai frutti di bosco ma
dubito questo momento che si tratti di
frutti di bosco sia quello non era vino
prima questo non sono pratico se
comunque non capito cosa devo fare
ragazzino ragazzo fermo a circa cassetti
chiavi qua è aperto non si può chiudere
la finestra europea non si può fare che
c'è una collana da un ora che non serve
non apportano anello con occhio rosso
dentro il bicchiere qui sembra giusto
anche dentro l'altro c'era lanciare un
occhio vero nell'altro suo nome proprio
anello con l'occhio rosso sono anelli
incassato una gemma che la forma di un
occhio perfetto a lo sapevo lo sapevo
devi fare sempre sta cosa in resine
tivoli staccare gli oggetti e poi
riattaccargli sa cosa non l'ho mai
capita ma evidentemente funziona così
allora con l'occhio può aprire la porta
con la testa cosa molto a lei mi scusi
mi scuso
guardi che ho trovato un anello nino e
adesso perché quello che trovo tengo ma
se facciamo ricatti soltanto io do
andare qua
che bella la gente che va tranquilla in
casa come se fosse casa sola no perché
magari è casa sua però vabbè sono io
quindi sono sono ospite almeno
l'accoglienza perché non mi ha chiamato
di screenshot cosa succede ok le
tecniche di produzione di via verdi che
rabbino colori prima venga sto
scherzando alcina dimitrescu sia free si
affida una tecnica peculiare leggendaria
che don albino un gusto corposo un aroma
intenso lo so io cos'è quella tecnica
sono polmoni di persone che
probabilmente ficcano nel vino per
questo l'ho visto da quello che
succedeva di sotto è però tento di
spiegare scientificamente quello che ho
visto quando chiave del cortile eccolo
quindi adesso valori sotto però c'è
mafalda sicuramente meno operare che
però allegro almeno jean disegni
allegrini como di mafalda
io vado di sotto è che non so dove sei
ma chi se ne frega io vado come si
accendono i colori né croce
allego meno male che almeno posso uscire
cosa ha parlato qualcuno sono pazzo io
sento è finito la shell quando quando
termina la mostra
che è incazzato allarme siccità ma
dovere va beh tu sei tu mi tratta come
richiami ricordo più alcina qualcosa del
gao yu mi ha mangiato il collo ma fa
niente da nel dettaglio quello noti
sempre quella c baldino giorno
fate tutto il vino quaglia non si fa
così pino comunque mi chiamo alberi e
vabbè finito store è finito così sono
otto
e finito è finito meglio degli altri
dissidenti voler più allegro grazie alla
maggior prego prego comunque ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto questo era
residenti vol
8 finley si chiamano ad esempio villari
cose nei ragazzi se mi sono piaciuto è
un mi piace anche per i soci al comando
trascrizione se non sarà così discrete e
noi come sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo
spavento horror è più il video con
pietro qualsiasi cosa sia
beh ragazzi
[Musica]